welcome back to CBS this morning we're
going to begin with the breaking news
overnight you've heard about it by now
the death of longtime Democratic
congressman Elijah Cummings this office
says he died early this morning in his
hometown of Baltimore after quote
complications concerning long-standing
health challenges Cummings used his
position as chairman of the House
Oversight Committee to repeatedly
question President Trump and other
officials he spoke to 60 minutes when he
became chairman back in January the fact
that we can look at anything is part of
the problem there's so much I'm serious
there's so much and you only have two
years that's less than that actually
less than that the Congress doesn't meet
with so many days in a year and all I'm
saying is that we've got to hit the
ground not running but flying Cummings
was 68 years old Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy the question is how
power lawmakers reacting to this very
unexpected news gale the grief here on
Capitol Hill this morning is bipartisan
one Democrat described Cummings as a
towering presence a Republican called
him an extraordinary man Cummings had
struggled in recent years with various
health problems he had a heart valve
replacement a couple of years ago he was
dealing with a knee infection and those
recent procedures had slowed him down he
took his last vote a little over a month
ago but his wife says this morning that
he worked until his last breath this
morning I spoke with Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer who called the news
a punch to the gut he was a wonderful
amazing man he always showed in his
professional life and personal life
strength
and kindness and compassion and humility
people would seek his advice I would
because you know you'd get a
dispassionate answer but a caring answer
cummings began his career in the
Maryland House of Delegates in 1983
where he served for 14 years before he
was elected to Congress in 1996
representing part of Baltimore and its
suburbs as the chair of the powerful
House Oversight Committee he was one of
a handful of leaders of the impeachment
inquiry into President Trump
House Majority Whip james Clyburn said
this morning today we have lost a giant
Elijah Cummings was a public servant to
his core during his career in Congress
Cummings has sponsored or co-sponsored
more than 5,200 pieces of legislation he
will be remembered by his wife and three
children boy all right Nancy thank you